and in some ways i kind of like the fact
that if you slow it down you'll get some
more from it yeah that's what canadian
lad does so well yeah
everything's slow i watch this at
point one percent point zero zero
zero one speed
and i learned nothing i learned that i
could speed this up a little bit and get
the same amount of context i learned
that if you slow things down enough
everything sounds like whale song
[Music]
what's going on there reject nation we
are going to watch today from new rock
stars doctor strange to easter eggs and
breakdown the man ea foss follow him on
twitter you can subscribe and click the
notification bell for our channel but
more importantly leave a like they'd be
very much appreciated let's see what's
going on right now people welcome back
to new rock stars i'm eric boss and this
is a breakdown of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness a movie that
teaches us all a valuable lesson about
what happens when marvel fans dream too
big the scarlet witch will break all
your toys and make you watch director's
damn game writes the mcu's first true
horror film that also rewrites the rules
of the mcu in so many cool ways so let's
break down this movie scene by scene for
the incredible attention to detail and
deeper layer of meaning that you might
have missed so the marvel studios title
card in this movie has been updated the
shots that previously showed moments
have all been replaced with wanda's
scarlet witch power up and one division
and various shots of doctor strange from
the 2016 film infinity war and end game
the final shot on the m of marvel
studios is strange's final scene in the
2016 film but in the inner top of the r
was wanda's team up with her family yeah
i got that so this is actually the first
time anything from a disney plus title
has made it into the title card just
proving how important wanda's experience
with their kids from that show is to
this movie also fun to note that behind
wanda's family in that shot is the west
view cinema with oz the great and
powerful plane a 2013.
also directed by sam raimi oz and its
witches definitely have parallels in
this movie story i'll get to that later
but the film opens in the gap junction
as defender strange races with american
chavez toward the book of ashanti
fleeing this ribbony monster marked with
runes later we learn a puppet
marionetted by the scarlet witch america
chavez is a young multiverse hopper from
the comics who comes from the utopian
parallel and you'll notice how the
opening words exchanged in this film are
in spanish underlining chavez's role as
the first latina superhero of the mcu as
well as the first lgbtq plus superhero
her star emblazoned jacket has a pride
flag pin on it i actually think it'd be
pretty cool to get a solo america chavez
film i know that's not the thing that's
really in demand right now but i really
found myself craving more from her
character the second time watching this
and seeing the world where she comes
from
no no
get a lot of lesbian love how cool would
that be to get in a marvel cinematic
universe movie and then cut out of the
chinese cut yeah yeah billion dollars
plus you know i just think zoshi gomez
is such a great job and i would like to
see more of her or young avengers
whatever honor jacket has also written
the phrase amores amore spanish for love
is love now the book of the shanti also
from the comics is a book of positive
counterspells sharing its name with the
seal of vishanti the shape formed by the
window of the sanctum sanctorum now the
gap junction is later described as the
space between universes and here it's
presented as a sacred church-like plane
but now in ruins as if the damage
already done to the fabric of the
multiverse entitles like loki and
spider-man no way home have taken a toll
on this place and this week marvel had
kevin feige confirmed that the
multiversal crises of those titles
directly set the stage for the crisis of
this film see i just wish the the movie
itself acknowledged that directly in
some way that way it really felt like
more of multiverse of madness yeah
absolutely you know that would be more
elevated and felt versus
having to look out for what kevin feige
saying in interviews
they connect if you read that quote the
platform with the book on it has 16
walkways converging out from it many of
them broken off a cool way of showing
how all the universes that connected
this are all backdoors leading to this
one book but many of those universes and
those pathways have crumbled and eroded
now defender strange seems at first like
the gallant to the goofus that we've
known multilingual only using defensive
spells like freezing and binding hair
tied back in a ponytail like the
chillest barista ever but we learned
in this case america he says this is the
only way and in the grand calculus of
the multiverse your sacrifice before it
gets cut off both of these lines being
callbacks linking this strange variant
to our doctor strange who after
sacrificing the time stone to thanos
infinity war told tony stark
there was no other way
and recently in spider-man no way home
told these exact words to peter parker
in relation to the deaths of norman
osborne and the rest being necessary in
the grand calculus of the multiverse
their sacrifice means infinitely more
than their wives you know that's
something that marvel can often sneak up
on you without realizing because i've
had this talk with a few people actually
can you define for me
clear-cut what is strange's character
arc in this film like what are some of
the lessons that he's learned some are
more obvious than others something that
kind of flew over my head up until this
breakdown was how this arc is a
progressive from infinity war to no way
home to what we're getting here now
versus establishing just where he's at
now but kind of like what they did with
hulk having his arc appear through
several films and i didn't even really
register like oh this has been occurring
from the start of infinity war this idea
of him having to like willing to
sacrifice lives that's just one layer to
the ark i think do you know where i'm
getting at
do you
do do you i don't understand what so
really no i no absolutely do actually i
think it's a really nice thing that
they've been it's a nice thing with
strangely this is a really nice really
nice lesson it's nice to learn to not
kill america
yeah you know it's always a good day
when you don't kill america but a
fatally wounded defender strange tumbles
with america through a star portal and
the camera work of sam raimi and
director of photography john matheson
rotate in a really fun way rotating raby
hot head shot having seen all of this as
a dream now this movie actually defines
all of dreams as us seen into the lives
of our multiversal selves a concept that
has been explored in real world
metaphysics but in the mcu poses some
interesting questions were the
nightmares wanda gave the avengers and
age of ultron visions of other universes
tony's dream that he told pepper about
in a video
last night i dreamt
we had a kid
so real
we named him after your eccentric uncle
uh what was his name morgan
of course they would eventually have a
kid named morgan so tony's dream there
likely was an alternate universe so
strange glances over his broken
wristwatch the one from the 2016 film
given to him by christine palmer and
broken by robbers outside comtaj a watch
face that he left broken to reflect the
unhealable wound of his hands and his
mastery of the mystic and mental over
the physical in this film the watch
symbol evolves to symbolize his forever
broken relationship with christine and
how that's actually okay strange uses
magic to tie his tie a reminder that his
hands are still damaged from his
accident in the 2016 film his hands
truly are his unhealable wound at the
wedding he passes this mom with two sons
just a little echo of the conflict that
he's about to face with wanda trying to
reunite with him
oh they're just background actors
whatever
and reveals he too dusted in the blip
and lost two cats and oh yeah a brother
too he ponders if there could have been
any other path strange might have taken
infinity war and by having to think
about this strange faces that his
sacrifice play at the time stone while
it eventually led to the avengers being
able to fix things sort of in end game
it also left survivors living with the
emotional toll of that conflict and in
wanda's case thanos using that same time
stone to render her heartbreaking
killing of vision meaningless strange
turns a glass of water into wine
freaking jesus over here also reminding
us of when he refilled thor's beer mug
in ragnarok really the best way to use
magic if you ask me strange apologizes
saying that he made sacrifices to
protect christine but that he's glad
she's happy really this whole movie is a
tug of war between sacrifice on one hand
and happiness on the other our heroes
begin this movie thinking that sacrifice
comes at the cost of personal happiness
but must learn by the end of the film
that sacrificing what we think we want
is really how we find deeper fulfillment
and inner peace but it also seems to
have this weird interesting layer that
happiness is not something you just
achieve
it's not a destination that you just
stay at ever and it's not something that
like a huge goal can create for you yeah
because that question is posed often
that's what makes sinner sir strange go
sinister
and his story when according to him when
he says christine asked him like are you
happy and then he went home and he's
like no i'm not encouraging time
to collide all the universes together
but by the end of the movie he's talking
to wong and he's saying like he thinks
saving the universe would make you happy
but i'm not yeah then he goes encourages
him
ungrateful slime strangers commotion
outside and tugs his red pocket square
revealing it as his cloak of levitation
and he would not believe the [ __ ] i got
in trailer breakdowns for theorizing
that pocket square was his cloak i love
how he summons it in freaking yeah yeah
you know
tony stark being caught by the mark 7
armor while falling in the avengers film
now this beast is initially invisible
similar to how the supernatural forces
of moon knight are initially invisible
to onlookers but strange decloaks it
trivial the squid monster of gargantos a
lesser-known comics foed and namor the
submariner and i love how the animators
use his single eye to characterize him
surprised when strange dismantles the
bust his eyelid crease to show anger his
pupil dilation when strange severs is
tentacle and of course a lot of great
details when the eye is about to get
skewered now danny's a lot of
personality this whole film with a
madcap feverish energy and here he uses
some great horns
now i love the music so much
so good so sinister
evoking mussorgy's night on bald
mountain yes there you go
[Music]
the back of the bus has an ad for la
llave coffee unlock a better day like
are they being spanish for key a hint at
strange's upcoming quest to use his
watch to unlock the back door and also
this spanish speaker superhero being the
key to his multiverse also nearby is an
ad for the magic of celestial team and
with strange jumps on the taxi there's a
sign behind him for a real brand which
might be a nod to stan lee whose real
name was stanley
no my definitely
tribute to him with stanley's pizza wong
shows up to try to restrain gargantos
gargantus uses one of his suction cuffs
to detach his canal maybe showing how he
does have some defensive moves against
the kinds of attacks namor might hit him
with he scales the building sam raimi
evoking his sequence with doc ock
scaling the building in 2004 spider-man
2. honestly right when he jumped off the
ledge and just started going into new
york that's when i had the thought of
this feels like sam raimi's spider-man
yeah like this feels like doctor strange
on the other side of new york while
spider-man is fighting something more
grounded
he's equipping
is dealing with this but it felt like
this is the rainy world at that moment
his new york world and i love that and
just something like this even more so
there was a moment that eric did not
point out where a guy is on a motorcycle
and he crashes into gargantos and the
second time around i was going
what was i thinking
i'm gonna save it i'm gonna sacrifice
myself for everyone to make you proud
mom and dad
my life's been leading to this one
back at the wedding behind christine and
charlie is a cameo by this movie
screenwriter michael waldron oh [ __ ] i
saw his name in the credits so i was
wondering where i learned garganto's in
the eye and then pumps that eye out with
its connective tissue looking a lot like
sam raimi's hilarious flying eyeball in
evil dead 2. strange and wong mentioned
their recent deal with spider-man and no
way home and america asks if he shoots
webs out of his butt harvesting tom
holland peter and andrew garfield peter
were both pretty grossed out by how
timmy mcguire peter's webbing multiverse
does it come out of anywhere else only
only the wrists now wait didn't strange
and wong forget about everything after
that movie's final memory wipe spell
well not exactly they only forgot who
peter parker is they still remember a
masked spider-man being part of their
history like notice here they never call
him peter parker and aren't really sure
how his webbing works just further proof
that he's just back to being a stranger
to them but they still know of a
spider-man existing in this universe
wait a minute that scene there i didn't
even question that at the time i know i
just go with the flow hey bug themed
heroes i wasn't even like no people
forget the way he recounts his
multiverse experience dealing with
spider-man would he remember about
multiverse with spider-man just every
moment where it's a ruler parker had his
mask off yeah it's a really patchy
memory and it's only those moments
that's literally how it's such a big
question now that's a big question mark
because yeah it's like the spell says
you race peter parker from everyone's
mind so that must just leave these like
weird gappy spider-man recollections
because the multiverse thing all
happened because he was
literally interacting with tom holland
because he was like i want to go to
college
none of that retains maybe he remembers
all those things as just him talking to
a masked spider-man now maybe that's how
it works could he talk to those other
spider-men who didn't have masks on
whatever but he doesn't know who any of
them are now either that's true because
he doesn't know any peter's park i don't
i think that would be as good as we
can't figure this out ever america shows
them defender strange's corpse on the
sanctum roof and strange buries him up
there saying that he's quote buried
worse and i'm dying to know who else is
in strange's life that he has buried and
wear now they realize that the magical
friends
was witchcraft and so we returned to
wanda's kitchen in west view using the
same one division episode two bewitched
inspired intro music which is composed
by the lopez's in this kitchen they have
a hamster cage labeled max maybe short
for maximoff replacing poor sparky the
dog billy and tommy return here back to
wearing the same red and green colors as
wiccan and speed do in the comics wanda
wakes up from this dream alone in her
bed and i love how the warm golden color
tone of the room shifts to a colder
desaturation just another example of
dreams being windows into her alternate
selves then wanda prunes branches in an
apple orchard just really cool symbolism
here she says apples eventually as they
haven't yet borne fruit as her efforts
to produce a light with her sons has
also been fruitless she prunes arabic
branches paralleling the ways he who
remains and the tva would prove it yeah
a good cause
for the multiverse you know like how one
is using the dark hole to x off
universes without her sons in them and
these being apples definitely reminds us
of the poisoned apple of the witch queen
of snow white which actually gets a
cameo later on in this film gotta say i
bet the production design and michael
walter when they watch this video you're
gonna be like wow this guy's making it
sound like we really thought about that
i'm impressed by the things we
accidentally put in here i just needed
to have her prune stuff
you know he has an activity you can't
have talking heads in a seat yeah i just
said hey have some business i don't know
give her some shears it's a veneer
let it be you know
everything in the film is intentional
that's what they teach you in school
strange says the flowers smell real and
wanda claims she put reality warping
witchcraft behind her after westview yet
even here the simulation seems real
enough to nearly full strange they chat
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
dangerous and then she drops the
branches in a crate labeled volkers or
bjolkers now in the comics wendell
volker is an academic who along with
reed richards discovers that baron zemo
has traveled back in time in a 2007
thunderbolt story no maybe this is like
the hovian estate that wanda has
overtaken temporarily somewhere close to
that mountain cabin we saw her in wanda
says there are other avengers and
strange mentions the archer with the
mohawk and several bug-themed crime
fighters of course referring to hawkeye
ant-man the wasp hawkeye doesn't have a
mohawk anymore no bring back the hawk
and he says i'll get you back in the
lunchbox there actually is a vintage
marvel superheroes lunchbox with
spider-man cap and thor on the front
fantastic four on the back and on the
side scarlet witch daredevil and
yellowjacket wanted mistakes using
america's name when strange hadn't yet
so she drops the illusion that red hat
is just as it did when it warped the
structures of west view and wanda vision
all of this coming from the darkhold
marvel's book of the damned which
wandered from the witch agatha harkness
in one division this whole dead
landscape is likely near that mountain
cabin from the watervision post-credits
scene all the plants now rotting more
and more as the dark hole corrupts the
landscape and actually in the background
of this burnt orchard are the ruins of
some structure that was probably what
the large house was when the illusion
was up that structure might be the cabin
she was in in the one vision
post-credits scene wanda scarlett which
wardrobe has evolved since we last saw
it in wanovision scratches radiate from
the heart region showing how her
fracturing of reality all stems
in the shape of vision's mind stone
reflecting how that heartbreak began
when she had to shatter her love's mind
in infinity war wanda says american
sacrifice would be
but it's also essentially what defender
strange told america so when juana
criticizes strange for giving up the
time stone and infinity war so that
thanos could render her heartbreaking
sacrifices revision pointless she's
totally right strange is a hypocrite
that doesn't seem fair this whole movie
is a strange being's hold you can't
sacrifice people stop sacrificing people
sir you suck strange you always go too
far and you sacrifice your friends for
the worst stop it the worst of the
universe you're gonna sacrifice people i
can sacrifice people universe you're the
worst what was the question you posed
yesterday oh about that realm like when
she drops the facade like where exactly
are we i mean the explanation that it's
like corrupted due to darkhold magic
actually makes the most sense to me
because i was like are we still on earth
she dropped the facade it was like where
on earth looks like this and has a sun
that big so the land itself was
corrupted by dark hole magic yeah i
guess so that's what i'm choosing to
believe wow damn dark cold
dark hold of madness back at commerce
wong explains that the scarlet witch was
prophesied to either rule or annihilate
the cosmos recalling what agatha read
from the darkhold your power exceeds
that of the sorcerer supreme
it's your destiny to destroy the world
commerce mounts its defenses master amir
returns to the 2016 film and we meet
sarah lightly based on wong's romantic
partner of sarah wolf in the comics in
the minotaurs
also from the comics sorcerers from the
hong kong and london sanctums joined
them remember the 2016 film established
the three sanctums of earth being in new
york london and hong kong and behind
that one guy the portal to london has
one of the city's signatures
because that always means a lot
and
emerald city writings surrender dorothy
and smoke this being another witch
demanding the magic girl from another
reality give herself
a great call damn
this whole movie over the wizard of oz
the shots of them running along a brick
road defender strange being the
brainless scarecrow who ends up wobbling
around puppeted our strange the
heartless tin man who cuts long the lion
gets his nerve the illuminati of course
the great and powerful oz ultimately
proving to be total
christine glenda the good witch who
ultimately teaches strange that there is
no place like his home reality i mean
the wizard of oz is one of the coolest
scariest and most visually invented
films of all time any multiverse movie
is right to follow its lead that time
remy's just out to make a good version
of all the greater the powerful see guys
see wasn't my fault i could have done it
the way they wanted me i wanted to do it
but they made me do it sort of way let
me do it better here than over there
just to prove myself again i just wanted
to remake wizard of oz i promise not to
take 10 years away from making movies
again that is a really great parallel
you know sometimes things sound like
they're reaching and anyone's breakdown
or easter egg video never us though if
we ever theorize we're always right on
the money especially when it came to
this movie all 46 cameos came true that
actually sounds very plausible and that
this is uh part of the intention was
sort of mapping it around it yes it's
wonderful i never thought of of the
wizard of oz through the lens of a
multiverse travel adventure but i think
yes it's such a great uh stand-in or a
great sort of thing to swap out because
yeah even though you know you basically
go from reality to oz there's still all
these other places that look very unique
inside of it and yeah all the different
characters matter and also about strange
doing a musical number about growing a
heart oh definitely yeah yeah that's
interesting and all the flying monkeys
wanda probes the camera's barrier and
then finds a sneakier way in by
whispering into the mind of one sorcerer
similar to how she dismantled the
avengers in age of ultron by implanting
visions in their temples and just
freaking them out she blasts the hell
out of kamartage all of its artillery
and its archers leaving one poor
sorcerer in pain that she just
obliterates which seems cruel at first
but the guy was also in a lot of pain
you could also read as an act of mercy
strange traps foreign
reality warping which his fingertips
have turned black the way agaves did in
juanavision when she used magic derived
from the dark hole they returned
wipes and distorts his
shoots all this with the same
claustrophobia and external evil trying
to break in that made the evil dead so
fun and like the possessed woman there
we only see the demon hands reaching up
to grab people which is also the kind of
imagery that you use to drag me to hell
strange realizes wanda's using
reflective surfaces to get in and as
they rush to cover each mirror in puddle
on the first one that strange covers for
just a few frames remy sneaks in one of
wanda's eyes glaring
returns to scare america and then her
hand reaches out through the gong as she
crawls in i love that shot
so j horror yeah exactly
or the grudge which sam raimi produced
the remake of absorbed and weaponized
and what if episode 4 and wanda begins
to drain america's power so strange
dives into america and they tumble
through the multiverse and it is insane
this is the matter with three cloaked
heads these are the faces of the living
tribunal the ultimate legal cosmic
entity in marvel lore who oversees
natural law of the multiverse with three
faces representing necessity equity and
revenge i like how here they are not on
the same head just three different heads
maybe away this universe in a fourth
dimensional space shows how they would
look from a fourth dimensional being in
the infinity gauntlet comics the living
tribunal acquitted thanos for snapping
away half of all life and the infinity
war writer said they actually drafted a
scene where strange and thanos would
have faced the living tribunal during
their wizard duel then they entered this
country and now you can just pass
through them
towards a great source kind of looks
like a mix of the celestials world forge
and eternals but i think we might be
seeing cerebro professor exodus oh cool
connecting with all the minds of mutants
then they fall through a freaking
beehive filled with bees like that what
it was yeah okay i was wondering on
america's finger that first triggered
her fear and opened the star portals
that took her moms from her is this what
the hexagons and the beekeeper from one
of vision were all about
can someone tell me please then they're
underground baby
and some of those fish swim out with
them back in the open air new york where
they pass taxis with the ads grind house
releasing which is a company that
remasters cult films that partnered with
sam raimi to restore the evil dead and
it's run by bob murray bob garrowski who
also co yeah
oh that is awesome yes it's actually
filled with stark drones from spider-man
far from home perhaps it's the reality
where they overthrew humanity then a wow
filled with bones true fire and
brimstone strange runs into a pile of
skulls other skeletons are climbing
lampposts made out of spines all the
buildings are made of bones i mean i
would say this is just the mcu hill but
this movie also shows us like multiple
possible hells and moon knight did just
explain that the mcu afterlives of the
egyptian underworld and the wakandan
ancestral plane are actually part of the
same realm just subjectively taking the
form of whatever the believer believes
spoilers these various hells might be
part of that same belief-oriented
afterlife system next a universe with a
t-rex fighting a triceratops then an
animated universe with some goofy
marching band music now this is not
exactly the animated style from what if
and they do pass that jonas and james
sign so this is actually the same spot
where they fought gargantos and this
interesting reality with the wreckage of
some propeller plane with green flames i
don't know i thought maybe this could be
the valkyrie plane from the first cat
film if it had made it to its intended
target of new york then
everything takes a cubic form i just
love how the break line between the
blocks separates on the teeth of
strange's open mouth then they shift
into sloshing paint reality where
america says she's been trapped in
before making it really hard to eat then
i love this an old-timey film
desaturated with wear on the celluloid
showing 1930s new york model t's the
brooklyn bridge i love this overhead
this is the world that steve rogers and
bucky barnes grew up in then this
interesting alien setting that also
looks a bit ancient because it includes
a stonehenge configuration remember thor
the dark world suggested stonehenge was
part of a coordinate layout to
triangulate the convergence maybe this
is the alien society who helped lay out
those coordinates then two more
futuristic looking realities then a
rocky volcanic setting with lava rivers
looking a lot like
the star wars universe actually in a
similar montage of what if episode eight
ultron infinity in the watcher that also
looked a lot like mustafar and they
landed
thor ragnarok even had uh one of the
star wars
jets
that's what they call them right where's
your jet luke uh [ __ ] like
expert yeah
well then it's canon now yeah it's
absolutely canon now how cool would it
be if they did manage to connect it to
star wars what this reminded me of
because there's been complaints of
people saying like there's not enough
multiverse action in here like actually
going through the multiverse and i
remember we joked around when we saw the
shortened version of that clip it's
going to be like x-men origins wolverine
where you see the trailer for origins
wolverine you go wow we're going to
explore so much then you realize it's
just a quick montage this did way more
than origins wolverine but i wasn't
expected to be almost right about that
like oh yeah we may have to go to like
two universes
yeah that montage is the thing that
contains the most like wow just
imaginative craziness
like pointing out the details goes yo
that was cool but there's no way i
anyone's taking away emotional substance
or context from it other than look how
cool that is yeah i want to spend five
minutes in each of these yeah why not
but no i was still in austin i still
think it's beautifully realized like
every time you show watch i'm like what
is it so it's so good and in some ways i
kind of like the fact that if you slow
it down you'll get some more from it you
know yeah that's what canadian lad does
so well yeah
everything's slow i watch this at
point one percent point
and i learned nothing i learned that i
could speed this up a little bit and get
the same amount of context i learned
that if you slow things down enough
everything sounds like whale song
and they land in dimension 838 a utopian
manhattan covered with plant life and
wind turbines all built into the
skyscrapers the empire state building
has a waterfall coming from it this
actually seems like the direction 616
manhattan was going in the mcu with far
from home revealing a new atrium
constructed into the avengers tower and
various fantastic four hints at the
ground level all the advances of this
reality were almost certainly
innovations of reed richards they're on
the roof of the 838
greenhouse and mound where defender
strangers buried back in 616. said he
had been on weird trips before of course
referring to the similar multiverse
montage from the 2016 film and the drugs
all the citizens wear monochromatic
colors which might just be a hint of the
cold functionality of the society the
emphasis being on natural beauty over
the artificial kind of beauty of fashion
and just visually for the sequence it
helps strange and america stick out like
sore thumbs here also a little detail i
thought was interesting if you look
around pretty much everyone is carrying
an umbrella that might be connected to
those rainbow-colored clouds overhead
which might be an indicator that in this
universe rain and weather patterns are
actually artificially controlled
scheduled on clockwork coordinated by
reed richards maybe by aurora monroe
storm as well a measure that they take
to help combat climate change ensure
plant life is properly hydrated and the
people who live here just kind of have
to deal with rain being part of their
lives all the time of course the traffic
colors are reversed green for stop thus
the x's red for go thus the arrows now
the fact that 838 proceeds on red when
we would stop does foreshadow how the
foolish illuminati is going to proceed
on the scarlet witch they definitely
should not our man bruce campbell cameos
sam raimi's star from the evil dead
films who came out in all three of his
spider-man movies and all those
characters were actually planned to be
mysterio quinton back i thought they
were gonna go there i know before sony
canceled it here campbell's playing
pizza papa a vendor who sells pizza
balls time to deliver a pizza ball
strange curses his hand to punch himself
in the face for three weeks a nod to
ash's cursed hand and evil dead two you
see all these things you were saying
about earth 838 when you elaborate more
on what they could possibly mean that
really makes me feel like i missed out
on something to explore because you
could be right and whatever you're
saying sounds accurate you know like why
do they all have umbrellas why are those
rainbow clouds does it have something to
do with that and the fact of this like
color coordination kind of evoking a
sense that there's a little
kind of a judgmental society in in
certain ways yeah because you're talking
about like the coldness of the
illuminati and i feel like that would
probably enhance the presentation of
when you do catch up with the illuminati
of understanding the society and the
world that they're at a little bit more
just would have been so awesome i would
have loved that man not now i'm not
feeling this is supposed to enhance my
experience and it is but it's also
making me wish it was longer well yeah
because the first thing america says is
like first of all multiversal travels
you don't know anything and i'm like i
want to learn a little bit about every
one of these worlds and the plot has to
move so fast you get the chance red
means red means go yeah yeah that's
right i'm sorry pizza that's i
apparently exist on another earth why
don't they exist here a memory lane bank
reveals the flashbacks of christine
giving steven that watch and america's
origin losing her mothers in the utopian
parallel but in the comics this was not
america's fault for even the bee's fault
and really her mother sacrificed
themselves and ended up disintegrating
to becoming part of the universe but
here in the mcu it's hinted that her
moms might still be alive so they arrive
at the 838 sanctum and the statue of
supreme strange which has been built out
into the street from the sidewalks the
cars have to go around it and i'll look
at it and pay respect the plaque reads
dr steven strange gave his life to
feeding thanos we express eternal
gratitude to earth's mightiest hero
earth's mighty ciro of course the
nickname for the avengers and comics
there's a rare book shop on the other
side of the street called mcleod's which
could be a nod to comics writer bob
mccloud who co-created the new mutants
with chris claremont mordo
2016 film strange says mordo dedicated
his life to trying to kill him referring
to that movie's post-credit scene where
mordo turned against all sorcerers too
many
never got to see any real conflict
between yeah i know
it's consistent
projecting one's consciousness into
one's alternate self and over this raimi
shows cross-dissolving montages that one
is ritual the visuals evoke the dream
sequence of rosemary's baby there's
surrealism superimposed shots close-ups
of the eyes and i love that symmetry
scores this with rock we hear some drums
electric guitar really this is the sound
of witchcraft in the 90s to me like the
craft buffy the vampire slayer i very
much dig it every time i watch that
sequence i think of robert rodriguez
specifically oh good call yeah totally
it's exactly what rob rodriguez would do
that like moody rock and roll thing with
the dissolves
you know mysterious such a rob rodriguez
motifs most of the the way this movie's
shot i immediately associate with other
sam bravey things i've seen that's the
one time i'm like oh a little bit of
rodriguez in here let rodriguez direct
to marvel you coward no do it do i do i
want please
i want him i'm begging you marvel if he
doesn't do a star wars that's the price
he won't do any more star wars you can
do some marvels don't do it already
black cat witchcraft but mordo drugged
the tea with green powder that also
powers the cuffs called the sands of
nisanti a spell from the comics that
prevents the usage of magic for three
minutes wanda dreamwalks into another
universe's west view house the camera
voyeuristically glides in and peeks out
from behind the staircase these point of
view shots evoking john carpenter's
opening shots of halloween the way wanda
creeps in here is very much like a
stalker
a 1928 walt disney short called the
skyscrapers now walt disney made oswald
shorts for universal before contract
dispute led to him launching mickey
mouse and steamboat willie so gasvald
has actually gained a cult following
over the years as the mickey who could
have been and i just love how he shows
up here in this alternate universe
that's so cool i love that
even disney honored it the champion is
still frozen mid-spill the peas roll
around on the plate evoking the way the
food squirmed around in the kitchen in
poltergeist an ocean churns in the
coffee cup an early sign of the
incursions that dream walking risks an
ocean similarly crashed through the
post-incursion universe of sinister
strange and a dreamwalking one that
takes control of this wanda giving us
this chilling moment when elizabeth
olsen looks directly at the camera
i see you i love it spooky horror trope
that we've seen in the closing shots of
horror films like psycho and paranormal
activity those shots are like ending
shots though yeah there's something that
was so eerie about in the middle of the
movie when that happens yeah absolutely
like it's so striking it's spooky so
spooky in that moment i like to think
that she just popped out behind every
audience member whispered something in
her ears get a refund
go to the bathroom refill your popcorn
how'd you like that avatar trailer sarah
breaks wanda out of this dreamwalking
state by stabbing the darkhold and sarah
burns crying the love of wanda that's
why torturing and the others to get was
actually a copy of the spells carved
into the walls of the temple on mount
wondergore which in the comics is a
place where the demon cafan inscribed
the spells that were eventually drafted
into the darkhold book this is also the
mountain where in some comics wanda and
pietro are actually born in the castle
of the high evolutionary we got a nod to
that comic backstory in one division
with the sighting of bova milk boba
being one of the missionaries annie
mintz
wanted pietro wundergore mountain is
where cathodon initially cursed wanda as
a baby though in the 616 mcu want a
vision established that she was born to
arena in oleg maximoff in sokovia though
in that flashback wanda showed she
already had as a girl low-level
probability hex capabilities so it
remains to be seen if the mcu will trace
that back to catholic's curse or if
they're going to define wanda as a
mutant or both wong takes wanda to that
temple all of their carves to look
exactly like the scarlet witch page of
the dark old that we saw in juan
division episode nine this temple's
guarded by hulking creatures that may be
based on the ingary catholics elders
spawn minions from the comics but when
they take a knee wanda realizes that the
chamber isn't a tomb but a throne
doesn't wong directly say at one point
like this is
something catholic though though
it's a line that's kind of easy to miss
for some reason i didn't catch it all
the first time i watched it i i did but
i feel like it is right after a moment
that maybe is like a crowd
expositionally explaining what's on the
wall i do wish these uh minions actually
did something in the movie
you know they threw a rock at wong
it was like
it was good rock though
they subverted expectations by bowing is
there's a dark hole in the 838 universe
can that wanda also become a scarlet
witch you guys are gonna tell me no
because scott which is the nexus being
but they don't talk about nexus beings
at all in this movie so yeah it's like
is this wanda the only scarlet witch and
the rest are just wandas with slider
powers and where's one other wanda's
husband he's drunk at the bar
yeah the universe
is deadbeat vision normal human yeah
office dad worker in the first episode
of water in this universe vision was
based on windows 7 technology instead of
ultron technology so he's really lagging
the altar she stands on is actually
carved with that same horned head figure
as we saw on the dark hold cover this is
perhaps the horned form of cathode from
the comics meanwhile variant christine
explains that they are in dimension 838
and she has designated strange's home
universe as 616. 616 is the numerical
designation of the primary universe in
the comics and until now the mcu has
really been considered earth 19999 based
on a joke by kevin feige that he planned
for the mcu to run for that many years
but now it is first codified as 616
which was hinted at in the tva's film
strip in loki episode one and an easter
egg on a storage locker and end game and
interestingly mysterious line from far
from home there are multiple realities
peter this is earth dimension 616. i'm
from earth 833. now quentin bank was
lying in that moment he was reciting a
script written by guterman so it's just
another uncanny coincidence they chose
the correct numerical bits of multiverse
travelers
gooder mint origins now christine
compares 616 steven to 838 steven using
his hand injuries a kind of multiversal
fingerprint so like for peter parker
losing a parent figure and the with
great power quote are absolute constants
for those variants their hand injuries
are the constant and on that screen you
can see stephen cell is d23 which is a
disney easter egg
[Music]
walt disney founded his animation studio
christine says that this is the baxter
foundation and not of course to the
baxter building but actually a fantastic
four in the comics strange speculates
that this could be part of the avengers
or shield or hydra hydra was an
organization that was tracking strange
since 2014's captain america winter
soldier what targets
you bruce banner steven strange anyone
who's a threat that being the first time
we're at stephen strange mission in the
mcu but mordo declares the illuminati
we'll see you now the illuminati in the
marvel comics is a six-member group of
leaders representing different super
factions you got tony stark leader of
the avengers charlton xavier leader
mutant kind reed richards leader of the
fantastic four doctor strange sorcerer
supreme black bolt leader of the
inhumans and neymar king of atlantis as
is the case here though their meddling
often gets in their own way serving the
illuminati are these ultron sentries
which are actually voiced by actor ross
marquan who voiced
what if in red skull in infinity war now
the baxter foundation agency master
impressionist 838 manhattan and the
interior is modeled on the lobby of the
british museum of london mordo
introduces the 838 illuminati lineup
including himself naming himself baron
carl mordo the character's name from the
comics strange dodge is the union jack
shield of captain carter leader of the
838 avengers played by hayley atwell
looking just as she does and what if so
presumably there are other avengers in
this 838 universe then there's captain
marvel maria rambo defender of the
cosmos lashana lynch returning from the
2019 captain marvel film presumably from
a history where maria not carol danvers
was irradiated by that lightspeed engine
then black agar
leader of the inhumans and keeper of the
terrigen mist on some mountain reprises
the royal from abc's short-lived inhuman
series now in humans are superpower
genetic experiments created by the cree
who live on the moon black bolts voice
releases a powerful sonic blast so the
guy rarely talks here he's seen with
this tuning fork headgear from the
comics terrigen miss meanwhile is the
kree technology that creates inhumans
via cocoon we actually saw this process
quake in agents of shield intelligent
mist may tie into miss marvel since that
is how kamala khan gets her powers in
the comics though the disney plus series
may be going in a different direction
then of course reed richards aka the
elastic mr fantastic of the fantastic
four played by fan cast dreamboat john
krasinski i like how he teleports in via
the square portal which is a completely
new kind of tech that we've seen in the
mcu it seems very much like the kind of
tech richards and dr doom used in the
comics it does fascinate me though i do
believe there were supposed to be seven
people on the illuminati seat and i've
seen photos that are like the illuminati
who's who's sitting there and i count
seven chairs um i've seen cause there's
only six right now yeah so who's the
seventh i'm like there's ultron bots so
if there's ultron that must mean there
was an iron man who created ultron and
part of this like trimmed down from two
hours and 40 to two hours and reshooting
did they cut out an iron man cameo would
they do that to tom cruise it just seems
so
weird like i can't figure out what the
point would be taking him out if they
shot that even if people had heard you
know the rumors flying around or
whatever it's still one of those things
where it's like you don't confirm it
people are still going to lose their
minds were they just misleading us
normally it's put less people in there
and then when they watch the movie there
will be more
yeah it's like put more in there and
then watch it there's gonna be one less
that's the new irony is that they're
gonna market us with something way more
broad looking and they give us something
a lot more don't take notes from sodie
strahange asks if the fantastic four
quote charted in the 60s of course
comparing them to the beatles like the
way bruce banner talked about the
avengers infinity war broke up like a
band like like the beatles and the way
toby and andrew thought the avengers was
a band and no way home well you don't
have the avengers is that a bad are you
in a band now strange is probably just
joking but ant-man director peyton reed
did pitch doing a fantastic four movie
set in the 60s like the beatles movie a
hard day's night and many of us have
speculated that the fantastic four could
have existed in the 60s of the 616 mcu
and the quantum realm the way that yeah
the fantastic four and hank pym ant-man
all kind of work together now reed
explains that strange's arrival at 838
risks an incursion which is determined
marvel comics for when universes collide
like a series of incursions between
earth cycloid worlds
1610 the universe of miles morales is
what led to the 2015 secret wars event
when all these variant heroes and
villains met in dr doom's battle world
which is why many believe that the mcu
might be headed toward a similar event
in a fifth avenger's crosstalk so cool
which in this case might be kang the
conqueror because we saw what may have
been incursions in the mcu in this
minute's intro video in loki episode one
and kevin feige just confirmed that loki
and silvi killing that kang variant he
who remains led to the sacred timeline
unraveling into various incursions and
that's really what set the stage for the
crisis of this movie and remember the
original kang variant nathaniel richards
was a 31st century descendant of reed
richards so really this is all connected
oh [ __ ] i totally forgot about that yeah
at the time of watching loki i remember
that but damn that is so true ah that
makes it even cooler yes loki does
figure it it does make it even cooler
holy [ __ ] i love that
it's a damn good breakdown this is a
great breakdown
second viewing made me appreciate it
that much more now this is making me
appreciate it that that that much more
so how come the spider-man stuff didn't
create incursions oh no no that stuff
was allowed to happen because of the
situation that happened in loki which
was
an ultimate incursion the tva can't
cause incursions for some reason yeah i
don't know are they like neutrally
charged in the multiversal scheme of
things where if like they show up
anywhere they're just not gonna have an
effect it doesn't seem as though but i
don't know so many questions
yes
what about like an infinity war when
they literally go to another universe
that doesn't cause an incursion
incursions happen when kevin feige says
that what you're doing
you never have and of course the sixth
member of this illuminati floats in
professor charles xavier with patrick
stewart returning for the fox x-men
franchise we should tell him the truth
but rather than the exact character from
those films which do have their own
convoluted timeline in which charles
dies in logan this charles has a yellow
hover chair a green suit the blue and
black tie looking exactly as he does in
the 90s animated series actually if you
listen closely the music of this moment
is ron wasserman's theme music from that
series
also when they introduce captain carter
they bring in alice of estries captain
america theme now there is one more
chair that's left empty on this
illuminati daisy suggesting some past
seventh member or just an extra chair
that they keep open now those ultron
centuries kevin feinstein's very iron
man since it was i talked too soon
mcu again in the comics it was hank pym
who created ultron so that seventh seat
could be his what if hank pym was there
the whole time it was just
for him
yeah he was like i'm just gonna sit back
and observe him yeah i'm not gonna jump
in he don't even
also in the comics the illuminati
originally reached out to t'challa the
black panther who ended up deciding not
to join the group that might be his seat
and the ultron sentries are just created
by reed richards so they finally
revealed the truth that during their
infinity war conflict with thanos 838
steven used the dark hole to try to find
a solution in the multiverse but in
doing so accidentally caused an
incursion that killed everyone in that
alternate universe now reed does say
that 838 stephen never told them the
details so there's probably more to that
backstory now charles uses this
telepathy to thank goodness show not
tell taking this to the day they beat
thanos using the book of ashanti look
closely at thanos corpse yikes his
double-bladed uber blade is broken and
plunged into his chest and importantly
his gauntlet does not yet have all the
stones we see the power stone space
stone reality stone and soul stones but
the mind stone is missing which tells us
that vision may still be alive in eight
three eight eight three eight strange's
fingers so is that fishing big and
wonderful
just like we saw on the fingers of wanda
in agatha black volt whispers i'm sorry
i like how his voice echoes louder and
louder with onson mount recording
multiple versions of this line building
up to a complete shout out to schoolway
showing how that sonic blast obliterates
strange wanda uses the darkhold temple
to dreamwalk into 838 wanda's house i
like that little detail of her
this
knocking
over
to us that in the 838 dimension wanda
had that perfect life with billy and
tommy so the mind stone being missing
from thanos's gauntlet and vision
survival might have been the key
difference there so this possessed wanda
attacks the baxter foundation and
charles tells stephen to get to the book
of ashanti and he says just because
someone stumbles and loses their way
doesn't mean they're lost forever which
is a direct quote from 2014's x-men days
of future past when charles said this
line to his younger self just because
someone stumbles loses their way it
doesn't mean they're lost forever now
that movie ended with charles in his
first hover chair we saw in live-action
film so who knows maybe that restored
timeline from days of future past didn't
lead to logan it could have led to this
and then after finishing off oh
fascinating
in their oil like it is blood recalling
that dark moment and age of ultron when
she ripped out ultron's heart and just
let it bleed that oil the oil streaks on
her face totally evokes sissy's basic
and carrying it totally influences the
blood bath water unleashes here also the
way her hand bursts out of the darkness
later in her mind reminding us of brian
de palma's final shot of that movie
so why did it
why didn't wanna grab some shoes in the
way yeah
her feet are in pain a lot in this fight
i'm like a couple pairs of tennis shoes
might have done the trick for you maybe
even some slippers she was just finished
watching moon night she was like i know
i'm going to get into some trouble here
i can you know walk around on the glass
and really feel the the penance for what
i'm about to do you know
it's all connected
she should have grabbed some shoes it
doesn't make me 40 minutes later most
dad joke i've heard something
hey it took only 40 minutes to get here
reed says that he has children of his
own and that their mother is alive
referring to susan storm the invisible
woman and their children franklin
richards and valeria richards and
confirming that lineage that will one
day lead to nathaniel richards kang
wanda erases black bolt's mouth like neo
in the matrix and folks this is the most
horrific death we have seen in the mcu
and i hate to do this but we gotta go
through it here just think about it
black bolt does not have to scream the
guy spends most of his time not at all
using his vocal cords but it's just the
panic of his mouth being erased that
rattles him to his core so he ends up
making the worst possible mistake of
vocalizing anything that scream
ricochets around his jaw you can see it
glowing on the other side
i did not notice that
holy [ __ ] i thought water just blew his
head up
oh no no no no i didn't catch all the
details but yeah it was clear like oh
damn he just tried to say something and
his head exploded i didn't i thought
wanda did that directly to him because
like the very next moment she like makes
him all like silly string
oh wow that's so cruel i know you guys
are like crooked
i don't know for the first time
what pay attention
whatever it's cool to see it now
we're on the same page
jerks canadian lad i know you're in the
comments
watching this
watch this at 0.25 speed i would've done
excuse me projectionist oh canadian lad
you should do that oh my god and then
right out of theater guys i'm here for
do you like what soups does we got an
early screening for thor love and
thunder but it's going to be special
we're going to watch this is 0.25 street
then reed makes the mistake of attacking
and wanda unravels his elastic body into
ribbons and then pops his head like a
pinata so then peggy and maria jump in
peggy using jetpack thrusters that she
presumably got from reed peggy spits out
some blood and then quotes cap's iconic
line of i can do this all day but then
poor peggy gets severed at the
midsection by your own shield actually
if you look closely after that shield
goes through peggy is still initially in
one piece but as the camera refocuses on
the shield in the foreground her blurry
form in the background slumps forward
but in two halves and then one it
collapses a statue and that's a bloody
shield that first strike
i mean each of these four actors must
have been directed on how to emote their
own deaths but there is no way all these
actors were on set with each other or
told how each other would die because
they should be screaming and horror
otherwise these four must be pretty
desensitized to people dying this way
charles enters want his mind that's a
good point it's a white void where he's
able to walk he was a black turtleneck
and beyond that door is a pile of rubble
including a tv set playing the intro to
one division episode one air sirens raid
in this revels clearly the rebel that
wanda and pietro were buried under in
sokovia when stark warhead landed in
their home but the scarlet witch's red
cloud closes in and she snaps his neck
making this the third time we have had
to see patrick stewart charles xavier
died now let's do it two more times
scarlet witch who does not care who she
hurts that she tries to be with her kids
are block points inspired directly by
the house of m comic event but whereas
that story goes deeper and deeper into
x-men lore make some major moves on
whether or not they even exist in
reality this movie's connections to
mutant kind stop right here i did have a
thought earlier today you know how x-men
the last stand tried redoing x-men the
last stand with dark phoenix
i would like them down the road which
seems even more likely because mcu is
all connected i think scarlet witch
elizabeth wilson is so awesome in this
movie brilliant in this movie it would
be cool to like do a more faithful house
of m because she's the ultimate threat
to like everyone she could rewrite like
all of reality you know yeah and so it
would be cool to really get the epic
showdown of everyone after you know
scarlet witch hey 30 years down the line
i feel like we probably will start
seeing like specific runs adapted maybe
yeah but do a good version not that dark
phoenix [ __ ] you know like a good one no
just keep remaking dark phoenix until
it's good and that's why i don't think
they could have done that now because it
probably would have made everyone think
of kind of dark music like yeah that's
the problem like oh woman gone crazy who
was once hero we must defeat her so
strange american christine flee as wanda
chases them her eyes glowing red looking
a lot like her zombie form from those
episodes of what if they find the hatch
the waypoint in the book of ashanti but
it is locked requiring a special key
strange's wristwatch give them to him by
christine another absolute element
shared by all strangers so they get to
the book of ashanti in the gap junction
but wanda attacks and a page from the
book burns out showing a star if you
look closely so remember the dark hold
page showed the scarlet witch this book
shows america chavez's symbol proof that
the girl was destined to be the perfect
antidote to the dark sorcery of the
scarlet witch and strange sees this page
burn which is how he knows what to tell
america in that final act strange about
how it banished to a post-incursion
universe which slowly melts that melty
and looking a lot like the way reality
eroded and what if episode four after
strange broke an absolute point and they
passed the floating honey beige 1973
oldsmobile delta 88 this same car sam
raimi puts it oh yeah gordon told me
ben's car spider-man movies and appeared
in the evil dead series and it dragged
me to hell now you'll notice this
incursion universe has two red streaks
racing through it the same color as that
looming crescent shape beyond the
sanctum stairway now kids what are
crescents crescents of course are formed
by the shadow of the earth on the moon
from the light of the sun behind us so i
wonder if this crescent could be this
dead world's shadow being cast on the
other world that collided into it maybe
earth 838 the reality fascinating
strange that collided in this universe
the dimension of sinister strange that
could have been the unseen annihilation
that the illuminati referred to 838
strange might have used a dark hole to
dreamwalk into sinister strange and
sinister strange tried to cast him out
and that war between the two dragged
their worlds together in a way that
killed everyone in sinister strange's
universe that could been the war that he
lost that he was talking about and the
guilt over winning that war might have
been what 838 strange confessed to the
rest of the illuminati and now these two
streaks might represent the lifelines of
those two universes synced forever
parallel but never touching yet still
way too close man you know they need to
do like some star wars animated [ __ ] you
know that just like [ __ ] just
explains all this stuff in all of the
gaps dives into all of it in animated
show format that'd be cool dude a
supplemental multiverse of madness
animated series please right how awesome
would that be yeah they call it what
it is i mean to be fair and what if
every episode started dr strange you
know one that's like specifically a fill
in the timeline you know i would i would
love that i would adore that yeah do it
do it i mean the creepiest detail about
this place is the fact that a freaking
field of bones stretches in front of the
sanctum everyone in this reality died
from an incursion but no human remains
are visible anywhere else that means
that these unfortunate souls of this
universe led to the sanctum looking for
sanctuary begging this strange to save
him and he watched as they died strange
brings up their dead sister donna whom
he says fell in the ice when they were
kids in the comics donna drowned after
getting a cramp in a swimming pool i
feel like that's a line that kind of
flies over people's heads a lot to me
to me the great and all-powerful greg
alba
as i have named myself legally by law
i've submitted the papers is that when
he says that because it's like such a
specific detail that's obviously
supposed to be like okay this must be a
real doctor strange but i took it as
like this is a more personal motive that
he still holds on to and that's why he's
so intent on like saving america chavez
is part of redemption for that because
it happened at a young age a little girl
said something about frozen lake star
looks kind of ice frozen i don't know
that's like the kind of [ __ ] you would
say eric yeah you go frozen invoking the
frozen stars trying to protect his new
surrogate little sister yeah falling
through the frozen ice the multiverse
yeah yeah i was just trying to think
like you and you're not even saying that
yeah what gives you we paying you for
yeah man we pay you to like marvel
marvel's right marvel pays you the right
mark
sinister strange reveals a third eye on
his forehead now strange sometimes has
the third eye in the comics as a
manifestation of the eye of agamotto a
way of showing the mystical sight that
the ancient one referred to when she
touched this spot on his head open your
eye oh yeah
but in this case the third eye
represents the twisted evil of the
darkhold the curse of kathan living on
these two strangest duel sinister
strange's sorcery is purple the same
color of agatha's magic the color of the
dark dimension and dormammu which is
something that's going to play a very
big role as dormammu's niece clea shows
up in the post-credits scene to work
with a stranger with three eyes during
the fight strange grabs the piano making
that same horror music sting that up
until now in this movie has meant fear
but instead now he weaponizes the fear
to lift the music notes off the page
interpretation i love this music duel so
much swedish restraints blocks the notes
by conjuring the five lines of a scale
which is how you would contain loose
notes and sheet music and forming the
new arrangement which plays as johan
sebastian bach's famous organ cords
strange
impaling them on the fence like saruman
but the third eye still opens because
the evil lives so strange now uses the
dark hole to dreamwalk into the one
strange still left in 616 the buried
defender strange resurrecting the corpse
now remember earlier wong told wanda
that no sorcerer can pass the barrier to
winogor temple so those souls of the dam
that attack defender strange are not
just an obstacle using them by turning
them into a new cloak is literally the
only way strange could fly over there
that's just a really smart example of
what screenwriters call economy of story
repurposing story elements we thought
were just set dressing or
characterization or raised stakes like
the defender strange corpse the watch
strange scene a star page in the book of
ashanti these souls of the damned and
instead giving them new practical
functions for the hero to advance so
when a bunch of nerds in your movie
theater started applauding in this
moment going yes it isn't just because
we love sam raimi's zombie [ __ ] i mean
we do it's because this moment was a
culmination of all these seeds that were
planted throughout the movie it's true
we were all like economy of story
good writing techniques
yeah man there's a lot of good good
economical choices made well i think
that is a great point because how many
times did we see zombie strange or
reanimated strange in the trailers like
so much
and both times i watch it i'm not even
thinking about it yeah right the first
time i watched it i completely forgot
that could happen or supposed to come or
whatever yeah and so when it starts
zooming in on the plot you're like oh
here we go oh yeah what christine says
to him you know there need to be a
strange alive on your earth and then
strange goes who said anything about
being alive yeah both times i'm like oh
yeah
yeah
it's such a rewarding uhly executed
moment now when the souls of the damned
attacks christine she banishes them with
the breezier of bomb goliath the same
article
you don't know how to use that do you
ah
oh crap yeah
that thing could have banished him to
hell strange arrives with the damned
soul cape and wanda says dreamwalking
you hypocrite the same thing kaiselius
shouted at the ancient one when she used
dark dimension magic hypocrite now
realizing america's power is needed to
beat wanda strange repeats this is the
only way so once again we have looped
back to the opening scene a defender
strange must once again face this moral
quandary of sacrificing america this is
what stream writing calls coming full
circle
coming full circle choice what's changed
what makes this strange different well
this strange trusts america to control
her own power because every portal she
opened in this film has brought them to
where they needed to go remember this is
the same strange who looked at 14
million 65 paths and found the one
correct path for his life and so unlike
all the other strangers who are always
seeking a better life including 838
strange who looked in a different
universe for one our strange finally
realizes he has gratitude for the path
that he is on because folks the true
ideal of america is not the pursuit of
happiness it's gratitude for what we
have so america punches wanda first into
hell wow i love that that's where she
thinks she needs to go but america
learns that the better destination for
wanda is just to give the woman what she
wants her west view home where her sons
actually see her true nature now based
on the other wandest bruises this is
actually 838 the same wanda that she
possessed earlier and you'll see how now
on the tv is snow white in the seven
dwarves remember in the alt universe
there is an alt universe walt disney
short starring oswald a lucky rabbit but
in this one it's the iconic walt disney
first feature length animated film snow
white and seven dwarves also remember a
story with an evil witch queen that
haunted me as a little kid so these boys
are on pins and needles about an evil
witch queen coming into a portal into
their living room yeah it's all great
like metaphors and [ __ ] but really i was
taken away is that these kids just have
a really unproductive unhealthy
lifestyle wanda just feeds them like
sugary fatty foods they sing a song
about wanting to get ice cream and
they're just like sat on the couch
watching tv all goddamn day yeah i'm
just arguing about baseball like read a
book read a comment to the children of
wanda and visionary
go do something extraordinary guys you
guys are some lazy ass
there's some average ass kids outside
play catch you know develop your super
speed and witchy power always eating
like such shitty like the last time i
saw you guys you were getting like fancy
ass sweets in the kitchen and now you
want ice cream and wanda like
there's an upstairs
you can get some privacy sister
all you do watch tv with her yes this is
the universe where she doesn't have to
do anything she doesn't even have to
leave the house ever she just
is with them while they watch tv
[Laughter]
and despite being possessed into doing
horrible things this other wanda
forgives the scarlet witch assuring her
that these boys will be loved telling
the mother what she needs to hear and so
wanda collapses the temple on herself i
forgive you for murdering everyone and
hijacking my body
wanda may be dead we do still have this
other wanda who was there for all the
craziest [ __ ] that happened in this
movie awanda who remember shares this
838 reality with mutants with the
fantastic four so some version of the
house of m no more mutants moment may be
on the way in the mcu
but that opens the question yes could
she also be a scarlet witch yeah can
there just be infinite numbers of this
nexus being doing no more mutants and
stuff yeah because if it is on the way
that would mean this wanda would have
the abilities of the scarlet witch to do
no more mutants even though they wiped
out like you know the main ones of the
illuminati well yeah the question to me
then would be is there another way for
her to achieve that without the dark
hold steroids
wanda just becomes an addict you're
shooting up on her butt
yeah yeah tommy billy's watch tv you're
huge
you gotta slow down bob
this isn't chaos magic wanda these
horses take these
in the final scenes of this movie
strange gets closure with christine he
leaves america in training at camertaj
and finally gives sorcerer supreme wong
the bow he deserves and most importantly
he finally fixes the broken watch the
camera transitioning from the broken
lens to clarity but that clear vision
proves itself a curse in the final shot
of the film the man is seen too well
with three eyes as the curse of the
darkhold lives on it's a scarlet letter
for his sins and a new unhealable wound
for the surgeon to suffer now i break
down the most credited scenes in another
video and we got lots of multiverse
madness videos coming down the pipeline
so subscribe for more takes on this
insane film and hey if you live in the
san francisco bay area i'm back
performing comedy live with endgames
improv at the stage where it's cool
my first show coming saturday may 14th
then after that every other saturday at
the same space coming out with improv
reactions follow me on instagram and
twitter we're moving to san francisco
and subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
that was a good ass breakdown good
lovely wonderful
[ __ ] no you're wrong they said that
wanda destroyed all the darkholds yeah
the other universe yeah that's why you
asked the question you're not wrong
that's why you're opposing the question
i'm right
i'm wrong
i cannot accept this
we must fight to the death
we must duel i don't i gotta find
another universe where i'm right
there's 14 billion possibilities i found
the one reality all right guys
thanks for being here eric you killed it
man you editors you did an okay job
it's all eric
yeah good job only to error only to eric
the other guys you might need to
reconsider finding you
yeah get out of here with this yeah man
because it's not looking pretty for you
i find a multiverse where your skills
are better appreciated
no you guys are just kidding
no crazy job seriously that's
good we're just being satirical anyway
we'll see you guys soon much love to
everyone including me
[Music]